[Applause]
[Music]
there are some moments in life they
never
[Applause]
forget the Depression hit everyone hard
no jobs no food we were broke looks like
you still owe a balance on this
semester so was that about making some
money you're the Rowan team you R you
get a part-time job included she place
to live am man crew is the most
difficult team sport in the
world the average human body is just not
meant for such
things most of you will not be chosen
beautiful speech
coach you're announcing the team today
are you going to make it we rode out of
need come on boys the need to stay in
school you need to eat to sleep we got
to keep these right long as we stay on
the team Washington Huskies coach is
bringing an inexperienced vat to
competition they said we couldn't
compete with the richest school for the
nation the Washington boat has taken the
lead Washington has done it I got 9
seconds under the course record Olympic
year this year Olympic here I didn't
realize that bunch of kids load like no
one else that's ever come through here
everybody else tires they just get
stronger we have a boat that I believe
could qualify for an Olympic spot hope
you know what you're
doing they said we couldn't beat the
Germans we got to beat those other
schools first but coach says we had a
shot maybe we can roll as a team if you
guys don't get yourselves figured out
you're not racing at all boys that
boat soer but they didn't understand who
we were the show was in this
book I don't believe what I'm
[Applause]
seeing that
best bir they
connected sweating
pain what is worth I'm proud of you boys
inspiring uh you missed the part where I
told him not to tip over and I won R for
your country Ro for each
other for all the people who never
believed in you us one as
one
[Music]